توقعات بتعافي قطاعي السفر والسياحه الحمد
لله في عام 2024 طبعا هذه المعلومات
اعلنها مجلس السفر والسياحه العالميه
مؤكدا انه يقترب من مستويات ما قبل كورونا
واخيرا التوقعات تقول ان عائدات السفر
والسياحه ستصل الى تسعه ونص تريليون دولار
في العام الجاري رغم ذلك لا يعتبر هذا
التعافي بشكل كامل لهذا القطاع على فكره
عادل التقارير بتاكد ايضا انه قطاع
السياحه في 34 دوله عاد لوضعه السابق في
عام 2022 من اصل 185 دوله خسرت كثير طبعا
من
يعني قطاع السياحه خلال جائحه كورونا
الابحاث ابحاث مجلس السفر والسياحه
العالميه تتوقع ان تحقق 50 دوله اخرى على
الاقل ارباح تصل حتى تصل للهدف المنشود
بالعوده الى السابق سابق عهدنا طبعا تحقيق
الارباح سيكون في هذا العام
مع التوقعات بعوده السياحه الى مستوياتها
قبل عام 2020 اي قبل كورونا فان العالم
ينتظر ايضا عوده قويه للوظائف المتعلقه في
هذا المجال مجال السياحه عدد الوظائف بشكل
كبير مشاهدينا يقال بانه 334 تخيلوا مليون
شخص كانوا بيعملوا في قطاعي السفر
والسياحه في 2000
2019 الكثير منهم طبعا خسروا وظائفهم في
طبيعه الحال طبعا مع ازمه كورونا زي ما
صار في كثير من القطاعات مش بس قطاع السفر
صحيح رغم كبير تؤكد احصائيات
يقدر باكثر من 70 مليون شخص ضاعت عليهم
الوظائف وهذه الوظيفه في ذلك العام العام
الصعب عن كورونا لكن الحمد لله الاوضاع
عمالها بتتحسن اليوم المجالات العلميه في
قطاعي السياحه والسفر تحسنت ففي 2021
و2022 العالم كان على موعد مع اكثر من 32
مليون وظيفه راويه الاقتصاديين يتوقعون ان
يصل عدد العاملين بهذين القطاعين الى اكثر
من
430 مليون شخص بحلول عام
2033 بعد عشره كلام جميل جدا واخبار جيده
جدا للعاملين في هذا القطاع واخبار سيئه
يا عادل احنا الاشخاص العاديين اللي حابين
نسافر لانه ما راح يكون جيد بالنسبه
للمسافرين زي ما بتعرفوا مشاهدينا اسعار
التذاكر يعني نار وراح ترتفع كمان راح
تواجه ارتفاع جنوني فضلا عن ارتفاع تقاليف
الفنادق بشكل كبير خليك روحي على
السياحه محليه بنضلنا بالبيت
مشاهدينا رح نبقى في اجواء الطيران وما
بين الصحاب السفر ليس حصرا على الاغنياء
يعني في امل الحمد لله رغم ارتفاع اسعار
التذاكر اذا كنتوا بتعشقوا السفر لكنكم
بتقلقوا حيال الناحيه الماديه هناك حلول
ماديه وفعليه لا تقلقون ولا تقلقوا دائما
بان بامكان الجميع السفر على اختلاف
الميزانيات كل ما تحتاج اليه هو اتباع
مجموعه من النصائح الماليه هذه الخطوات
البسيطه اللي من الممكن من شانها ايضا
توفير الكثير من المال اثناء السياحه والس
فر
ومنحك فرصه القيام برحله ممتعه
باقل التكاليف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات